ma sei ancora letto alzati su che thor
di devi andare a scuola non ci voglio
andare a scuola o troppo somma non
iniziare marina e non iniziare la febbre
sempre la febbre e tu eh sì sì cioè i
video non tentino di a sentire scotto
mamma queste ditte mi stressa un crollo
psicologico devo riposare mamma ma oggi
c'è sciopero e lo sono ricordato adesso
sciopero di che sciopero sciopero
d come tipo solidarietà per i bisognosi
e un nuovo tipo di visto vestendo mamma
ti giuro che questa volta c'è sciopero
veramente ti dico anche di cosa allora
cisl cgil e gtl e cosa sarebbe questo cd
l nuovo un nuovo sindacato si sono
sveglia
mi sto solo preparando lentamente ma
oggi non posso andare a scuola e perché
sentiamo perché ho scoperto questa nuova
youtuber che si chiama marina e mi
piacciono un sacco sui video però per
iscriversi al canale e cliccare sulla
campanella reach in altre istituzioni ci
vuole un po di tempo quindi mi devi dare
un po di tempo tipo tutta la mattinata
per farlo
ah sì vediamo vediamo cosa ha ragione
iscrivetevi subito al canale di marino e
cliccate la campanella
visto che ha messo un secondo ma
ambiente lava coste scuse mamma inutile
che vado a scuola perché la prima ora
non c'e lezione la prof è malata
entra una seconda così dopo ancora un po
dovresti saperlo quanto sono fragili nei
bronchi se esco con questo freddo mi
prendo una broncopolmonite
vuoi che vi succeda questo tuo figlio
mamma non posso andare a scuola perché
stavo sognando era un sogno bellissimo
parlava del bene che ti voglio mamma non
hai capito
l'ho appena scoperto c'è stata una
perdita nei bagni della scuola e
l'edificio inagibile
se e come fai a saperlo sentiamo chiama
l'intuizione mamma non posso andare a
scuola perché sto dormendo sono
sonnambula e non si possono svegliare i
sonnambuli sai
mamma lo puoi capire ma temendo c'erano
i mostri dei soldi
zauri era mi seguivano spaventati
non ce la faccio affrontare la realtà ti
prego fammi dormire ancora beretta e
perché stavolta non puoi andare a scuola
mamma non puoi capire medio pazzerello
punto il sito affidabilissimo appena
letto c'era poca liste non si può uscire
cioè allerta network espone sono chiuse
ma mola la saranno due gocce dai non
fare ogni volta la tragedia dai quasi ci
sono sacche d'acqua che crollano dal
cielo mamma mia appena arrivata la
lettera da hogwarts mi hanno presa
domani parto
eccola dove era la mia bolletta del gas
brava expelliarmus hai finito questa
attenta è che se non ti faccio
l'incantesimo io e faccio sparire tutta
la baracca qui va bene muoviti mamma mi
sono arrivate tutto troppo male un'altra
volta e non è avuta già scorsa settimana
ha ragione allora è grave e gravissimo
bisogna dare da ginecologo subito no non
posso andare a scuola e sai perché
perché sto preparando un esame e se non
posso quell'esame mi bocciano e semi
boccia lo devo rifare l'anno
e se ripeto l'anno non mi prendono
università e se non vi prenderò
università tauro è se non mi laura lo
trovo lavoro e se non trovo lavoro muoia
di fame come questo per tua figlia è
mamma sto studiando troppo ultimamente
la stanchezza accumulata che già proprio
mentalmente non sono pronta a studiare
altro devo fare un po di pausa perché
sennò pazzesco cioè troppo studio troppa
cultura a qui dentro
ma come non è mai sentito parlare della
teoria che dice che le persone che
riposano di più hanno più successo nella
vita
assolutamente no caldo cosa hai detto no
dico perché sono troppo calda mamma
guarda si è spento mamma ti giuro 54
grammi è gravissimo eccoci purtroppo
arrivati alla fine del video spero
tantissimo che vi sia piaciuto mi
raccomando fatemi sapere con un commento
qui sotto se avete già utilizzato una di
queste scuse o se avete trovato delle
idee degli spunti per le nuove scuse da
utilizzare
ricordatevi inoltre di seguirmi su tutti
gli altri social facebook installa e
tiki toki vi mando un bacione e ne torno
a dormire è retto d'oro ciao
[Musica]